>> Tucker: A RUSSIAN ATTORNEY
BECAME FAMOUS FOR MEETING WITH
DONALD TRUMP JR.
THIS WAS THE SMOKING GUN OF
RUSSIAN COLLUSION THAT YOU HEARD
ABOUT FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS ON
CABLE NEWS.
THAT ONE MEETING WAS GOING TO
BRING DOWN THE ADMINISTRATION.
IF YOU CONDUCTED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE IN THE 2016 ELECTION,
SHE WOULD BE ONE OF THE VERY
FIRST PEOPLE THAT YOU WOULD TALK
TO OBVIOUSLY.
SO HOW IS THIS FOR WEIRD?
IN A RECENT INTERVIEW WITH THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS, THE SAME WOMAN
SAYS THAT SHE WAS NEVER EVEN
CONTACTED BY SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER.
SHE'S DONE NO INTERVIEWS WITH
ANY FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS.
THAT'S WHAT SHE SAYS.
HUH?
HOW CAN THAT BE?
IF IT'S TRUE, IT'S SHOCKING.
IT'S ONLY SHOCKING IF YOU STILL
THINK THIS INVESTIGATION IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
IF IT IS, IGNORING HER MAKES
SENSE.
BUT IT'S NOT ABOUT COLLUSION OR
RUSSIA AND NEVER WAS.
IT WAS AN ATTEMPT TO UNDO
ELECTION RESULTS FROM DAY ONE.
NOW IT'S TOO OBVIOUS TO IGNORE.
JOEL PAYNE IS FORMER DIRECTOR OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN ADVERTISING.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: THERE'S A LOT WE
DON'T KNOW.
SO I'M TAKING THIS RUSSIAN
ATTORNEY AT HER WORD THAT SHE
WASN'T CONTACTED BY
INVESTIGATORS.
IF THAT'S TRUE, STIPULATING IF
IT'S TRUE, THERE'S NO OTHER
EXPLANATION OTHER THAN MUELLER
ISN'T REALLY AFTER MORE THAN
1 1/2 YEARS LOOKING INTO RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
HOW COULD YOU SKIP HER?
>> IF WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THIS
LAWYER AT HER WORD AND WHAT BOB
MUELLER HAS DONE AND THAT HE'S
BEEN RESPONSIBLE WITH THE
INVESTIGATION AND PROBABLY A
REASON SHE'S NOT BEEN CONTACTED
YET.
THE INVESTIGATION IS NOT DONE.
IF SHE HAS SOMEBODY THAT THEY
DETERMINE IS MATERIAL TO THE
CASE, THEY WILL TALK TO HER.
>> SHE IS THE CASE AT LEAST AS
IT'S BEEN UNDERSTOOD PUBLICLY.
A TON OF LEAKS.
SO WE KNOW A LOT.
SHE MET --
>> DO WE LIKE LEAKS TODAY?
>> Tucker: I'M A JOURNALIST.
I LIKE LEAKS.
BUT THEY DISCREDIT
INVESTIGATIONS.
INVESTIGATIONS ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE LEAKED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I ALWAYS WANT TO KNOW THOUGH.
HERE'S THE POINT.
IGNORING HER ISN'T POSSIBLE IF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DISCOVER
IS WHETHER OR NOT THE RUSSIANS
PLAYED A ROLE IN THE OUTCOME OF
THE 2016 ELECTION.
WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN THIS
INVESTIGATION, WHATEVER IT IS,
ISN'T REALLY ABOUT THAT.
WE WERE LIED TO.
IT'S ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
SO SHOULDN'T WE BE -- SHOULDN'T
WE PAUSE AND SAY WAIT A SECOND.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> TUCKER, I HAVE TO DISAGREE
WITH YOU.
EVEN THE PARTS THAT DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH COLLUSION,
MUELLER HAS REFERRED TO THE
PERTINENT JURISDICTIONS.
BOB MUELLER IS A MAN OF HIGH
REGARD.
HE'S BEEN LAUDED BY DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS --
>> Tucker: I DON'T CARE ABOUT
THAT.
>> YOU DON'T CARE --
>> Tucker: I'M AN AMERICAN.
>> IT SHOWS THAT HE HAS MANAGED
THE CASE THE WAY HE SHOULD.
LET'S LOSE SIGHT --
>> Tucker: I'M NOT ATTACKING
MUELLER.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
I'M NOT ATTACKING MUELLER.
I NEVER WILL UNLESS THERE'S
CAUSE TO DO IT.
I'M CONCERNED THAT THE REST OF
US ARE SOLD ON WHETHER RUSSIA
HACKED OUR ELECTION OR
DEMOCRACY.
THE OTHER CHANNELS WENT WALL FOR
WALL OVER A YEAR.
WE WENT TO WAR WITH RUSSIA AS A
RESULT.
WE KIND HUNDREDS OF SYRIANS.
NOW IT'S LOOKING LIKE IT'S NOT
IN PLAY.
WHY SHOULD WE FEEL LIED TO?
>> THREE MEMBERS OF THE
PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN TEAM
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THEY HAD A
ROLE IN WRONG DOING --
>> Tucker: FOR COLLUDING WITH
RUSSIA?
>> WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY --
>> Tucker: WE DO.
I'VE READ THE INDICTMENTS.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FULL
SCOPE --
>> Tucker: I'VE READ THE
INDICTMENTS OF THOSE THREE
MEMBERS.
WHATEVER.
PAPADOPOULOS --
>> PAUL MANAFORT RAN THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: PAPADOPOULOS,
WHATEVER.
BUT HERE'S THE POINT.
NONE OF THEM PLED TO ANYTHING
HAVING TO DO WITH RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
IF IT DOES COME TO THAT, WE
DISCOVERED THAT NOBODY IS
CHARGED WITH COLLUDING WITH
CHARGE AND THERE'S NO EVIDENCE.
WON'T YOU HAVE CAUSE TO FEEL
LIED TO?
>> NO, I PERSONALLY DON'T.
I KNOW WHAT YOU WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT IS THE DNC LAWSUIT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> THE DNC IS TRYING TO PUSH THE
PUBLIC DIALOGUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A SITUATION
LIKE THIS HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE HAD A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT TRY
TO COMPROMISE THE RESULT OF OUR
ELECTION.
WE CAN NEVER ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN.
REGARDLESS OF WHO YOU VOTED FOR
SHOULD CARE ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: THEN WHY DOES THE DNC
PUSH ELECTRONIC VOTING?
THE ONLY WAY TO SECURITY YOUR
VOTE IN A FOOL PROOF WAY IS WITH
PAPER BALLOTS.
THEY DON'T CARE AT ALL ABOUT
FOREIGN INTERFERENCE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT.
IF THEY CARED, THEY WOULD BE FOR
PAPER BALLOTS.
THEY'RE NOT.
>> TUCKER, A DISAGREE WITH THAT.
>> Tucker: THEY DO.
>> THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT APPLES
AROUND ORANGES HERE.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE SAYING I
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS HACKING.
THE ONLY WAY THEY DO THAT IS
ELECTRONICALLY.
WE DON'T WE HAVE PAPER BALLOTS?
THAT'S THE WAY TO PRODUCT
YOURSELF.
>> IF I GET MUGGED ON MY WALK
HOME, I'M NOT BLAMING THERE'S A
LIGHT OUT TWO BLOCKS AWAY.
I'M BLAMING BECAUSE SOMEBODY
MUGGED ME AND I WANT TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF IT.
>> Tucker: MAYBE YOU SHOULD STOP
TAPING HUNDRED DOLLAR BILLS TO
YOUR FEST.
THAT INCREASES THE RISK.
>> WE'LL AGREE TO DISAGREE.
LAST QUESTION.
THE DNC IS TAKING A POSITION
THAT IT OUGHT TO BE ILLEGAL TO
PUBLIC ACCURATE INFORMATION IF
THAT INFORMATION HAS BEN TAKEN
FROM AN E-MAIL ACCOUNT.
THAT WOULD HAVE PREVENTED THE
PENTAGON TAPERS, PRIVATE
INFORMATION PUBLISHED PUBLICLY
BUT IT WAS ACCURATE.
WHY WOULD THE DNC BE ATTACKING
THE FREEDOM OF THE PRESS?
>> YOU KNOW THE DNC IS NOT
ATTACKING THE FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS NOT DECIDED TO DO.
GET TO THE BOTTOM --
>> Tucker: THEY'RE TAKING THE
POSITION --
>> ANY OTHER TAKE ON THAT IS
DEFLECTION AND IGNORING THE
ISSUE.
>> Tucker: THE DNC SAYS IT'S
ILLEGAL TO PUBLISH THESE
E-MAILS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE SAYING --
>> YOU'RE SAYING IN THE ABSENCE
OF PRESIDENTIAL LEADERSHIP,
WE'RE GOING TO PUSH THE ISSUE
THROUGH ANOTHER WAY --
>> Tucker: AND SHOULD IT BE --
>> THEY HAVE DONE THIS BEFORE.
THEY DID IT AGAINST NIXON.
THEY HAVE SUED TO LEARN
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
IN PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGNS
BEFORE.
>> Tucker: SHOULD IT HAVE BEEN
ILLEGAL AS THE DNC SUGGESTED FOR
NEWS --
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY'RE
SUGGESTING.
WE DISAGREE ON WHAT WE READ.
>> Tucker: I'M TAKING THEM AT
FACE VALUE.
MAYBE METAPHORICALLY THEY'RE NOT
SAYING THAT.
LITERALLY THEY ARE.
>> YOU KNOW GOOD AND WELL THE
DNC DOES NOT DISAGREE WITH
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHO IS SITTING IN